all right let's turn to battleground
pennsylvania now in the race for u.s
senate between john fetterman the
democrat and dr mehmet oz the republican
it looks like we are finally going to
see those two candidates go head to head
in a televised debate fetterman's
campaign agreeing to take the stage on
october 25th
in harrisburg the announcement comes
after weeks of delay and concern about
fetterman's health and his ability to
actually serve in that role joining us
now for more on this is host of the
reuben report dave rubin author of don't
burn
this country dave great to see as always
john i apologize for wearing a jacket
and shirt as opposed to the john
fetterman fetterman or fetter woman
hoodie that is usually accustomed to
wearing i i thought this is the john
bachman show i wanted to show up
properly uh but maybe i should have just
worn a hoodie we try to keep things
classy dave but i do appreciate your at
least you know acknowledgement that we
could have gone with some larping here
some john fetterman larping we could
have grown some you know your facial
hair is not experimental i guess his
is considered experimental a little too
old for that but we wanted to compare
and contrast candidates not just senate
candidates but other candidates as well
and we had to ask this question who is
the more
i guess the worst maybe the worst
candidate out there on the campaign
trail today it could be john fetterman
or it could be charlie crist i think we
have some visual evidence to help you
know set this up here's i think charlie
crist
where do you stand on vaccine passports
and businesses
we should have vaccine passports i think
that's important
okay so charlie crist is running against
ron desantis on a platform of supporting
teachers unions and vaccine passports
and mass mandates and then we have john
federer in a different situation he's
having a little trouble with his own
words because of his stroke
it's such the most important race
for the senate here for 22.
we have to replace
pet toomey
oh no
so that's hard to watch too with
fetterman and we're not trying to make
fun of the
aspect of that but neither one of these
guys are good candidates you got charlie
crist who speaks too much probably and
john fetterman who can't really talk at
all who's the worst of these two in your
opinion dave
you know i'm gonna let it slide with
fetterman because of the stroke or
whatever but yes it is a little bizarre
that the democrats seem unable to find
candidates who can string together a
full sentence whether it's biden or
fetterman or kamala who actually does
put the sentence together but it just
doesn't make any sense or it's just
completely circular look chris is the
worst candidate running right now across
the country because he is absolutely
nothing if he is anything it is the
thing that people hate about politicians
he is a former conservative republican
who has flip-flopped on every single
issue the idea that someone who dare was
for vaccine passports would show their
face in the free state of florida and
say that they're gonna run for governor
he's absolutely nothing he has he has no
support desantis obviously is gonna
crush it as he well should i mean he in
essence i think is although it doesn't
say it on his desk i think he basically
is the president of the united states in
terms of leadership at this point but
the the democrat party in florida
fortunately is in shambles here and that
and kristi is just the sacrificial lamb
they basically were like look can we
find anybody who is willing to do this
you know chris is just like i have
nothing to do nobody likes me i'll get
out there the only way this is going to
make sense to me at the end of this is
if charlie chris pulls off his mask and
it's charlie chris the republican
underneath and he said i fooled all you
democrats for the last four years i
pretended to be a democrat and i ran the
worst campaign ever just to make it
easier on ron desantis and as it relates
to fetterman again it's not the health
issue as much but we learned this week
dave after criticizing dr manaz for
owning multiple properties we found out
that john fetterman owns eight different
properties in braddock pennsylvania so
he's sort of a real estate magnate
himself i don't know if braddock is the
best place to be investing in real
estate but there you go
and also speaking of um terrible
gubernatorial candidates related to
charlie chris how about stacey abrams
let's take a look at her
i have never denied that i lost i don't
live in the governor's mansion i would
have noticed
and there's this clip that's going
around and it shows me saying that we
won and what i was referring to was that
we won in terms of communities that were
long left out of the electoral process
oh okay well let's play the clip that
she's talking about just to be sure i do
have one very affirmative statement
today
we won you refused to concede and say
that you lost do you stand by that
decision today absolutely the election
was not fair the process was not fair
was the election in georgia statewide a
free and fair election it was not a free
and fair election
hmm
they'll say
she she literally went on the view the
show that she was on saying she didn't
do the thing that she did to tell them
i mean you can't make this up you cannot
make this up with these people but as
i've been saying for quite some time
this is the one type of privilege that
exists in america democrat privilege
they can question elections they can lie
about everything they can spread
disinformation
and they get away with it and nobody
gets banned and everyone's on facebook
and twitter and we don't have to have
meetings at the white house with big
tech to figure out how to deal with them
but you know if the rest of us dare
question anything or just you know try
to figure out what time it is
we're on a list yes and how dare you
retweet or repost anything that liberals
post because then of course yeah anyway
that'll get you through you know what we
say they know that we know that they're
lying yet they lie anyway dave that's
that's the key phrase all right let's
talk about president biden's visit to
detroit yesterday and i was curious
about this because he seemed to be
having a great time he even had a tick
tocker along for the ride to follow us
every move he played in that yellow
corvette
you know he seemed to be having a good
time like i said meanwhile we were
hearing about this looming railroad
strike potentially
i'm not sure if that was a real thing or
not maybe it is maybe it's not but if
this was really a big concern
effectively could shut down our entire
economy should joby joe biden be playing
with electric cars in detroit
look the cynical part of me which at
this point is most of me related to this
administration is that they are
intentionally doing everything wrong if
there is an economic policy or a foreign
policy
issue or a border issue whatever it
might be a covid related issue if there
is a way of doing the wrong thing that
is what they will do every time if we
have an inflation problem what will they
do
spend more money while calling it
inflation reduction if we have a
transportation problem what will they do
they'll drive up the price of oil
everything that they do is backwards so
yes it should not surprise anybody that
joe shows up and he sits in the fancy
car by the way he was holding
gretchen whitmer the uh the governor of
uh she's the governor of illinois
holding her name hold up governor of
michigan sorry holding her hand as he
walked through the place i mean the
optics of it were just terrible but none
of this should surprise anybody it is
what it is with this guy and and you
know he goes where they tell him to go
and he says often poorly or mangled uh
what they tell him to say well if hunter
and ashley biden cared about joe biden
they'd be talking about taking his car
keys away it's a conversation a lot of
kids have to have about their parents
maybe that time for joe biden um i don't
know but uh let's talk about what i call
the alternative infrastructure dave
remember when alternative used to be
cool when we were teenagers back in the
90s
it's going to be cool again i think
because what i'm referring to is what
rumble is doing what you're doing with
socials uh you know the there are with
locals there is a
alternative infrastructure being built
for big tech and we learned this week
too that there's a chinese spy working
at twitter nobody seems to care twitter
too much there are no chinese spies
working at locals right
there are no chinese spies working at
locals i can be quoted on that um i also
never slept with the chinese spy
unlike eric swalwell uh the congressman
from california uh but joking aside yes
rumble and locals locals was a company i
started we eventually merged with rumble
we are building the alternate pipes of
the internet we need a we we basically
need an all-new internet from the bottom
up where not every website is hosted on
amazon aws where they can just literally
push a button or swipe a screen and blow
you up as they did to parlor we need to
have places where speech is treated
neutrally where there isn't one side
putting their foot on the scale for the
other side that is exactly what rumble
is doing that is what locals is doing
and uh yeah there's a lot of there's a
lot of good energy i think something's
happening in new york next week related
to all of this can we talk about it or
are we going to get in trouble
i'm not i'm honestly not sure but uh
okay let's not do information out there
maybe other people could talk about it
yes they can find good things happening
there look no it is it is now it is
public knowledge that rumble is going
public okay and in my opinion for the
first time and i speak just for myself
when i say this there will be a company
a big tech company that is specifically
it is baked in that free speech is baked
in the ethos of the company so free
speech is going public that is that is a
beautiful thing and it is what we have
all been waiting for yeah well we end
our fridays shows finally some good news
we'll do a little good news on thursday
and that's that is a you know something
to look forward to over the horizon more
free speech rumble's leading the way on
that along with you and local great to
see you dave as always
good to see you john and again i'm sorry
about the sweatshirt thing i i should
have put it on him next time we'll we'll
figure something out halloween's right
around the corner federer means a great
costume too for halloween if you need
one great to see you today if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell